signataire d'un accord historique
amorçant l'autonomie des territoires
occupés prix nobel de la paix cette
année il y as arafat a de bonnes raisons
de croire au père noël
le chef de l'olp il a rencontré
aujourd'hui à gaza reportage charles
enderlin s'est juché sur les motos de la
police palestinienne que le père noël
arrive à l'école catholique de gaza
le président est là il adore ce genre de
cérémonie la naissance de son premier
enfant est prévue pour l'année prochaine
son cadeau un verset du port un père
noël ou pas la sécurité très importantes
yasser arafat ne se déplace qu'en tour
et de dizaines de gardes du corps
cette fête a valeur de symbole les
catholiques ici ne ressentent pas la
pression des islamistes
la plupart de ces écoliers sont
musulmans leurs parents les ont inscrits
à l'école du patriarcat latin en raison
de la qualité de l'enseignement
même les enfants de certains leaders du
fama sont étudiés ici plutôt que dans
une école islamique alors à gaza noël
est devenu une fête patriotique destinés
aux enfants
sur les 200 familles catholiques que
compte le territoire autonome quelques
dizaines assisteront à la messe de
minuit dans l'église de la sainte
famille selon la tradition après s'être
enfui de bethléem jésus marie et joseph
sont passés par gaza pour se rendre en
egypte